blood it is something we all have but
it's getting harder to keep up with the
demand for those in emergency care who
need it Brian Will finds out what the
need is like here in Las Vegas and how
new rules are allowing more and more
people to donate
donors here at the American Red Cross
are doing just what this bus says
they're giving their blood to help not
only those here in Las Vegas but also
those affected by those storms in the
midwest if we don't help when we can how
can you ever expect to be on the other
end and feel good about it for Scott
Folsom a retired police officer it comes
natural to help but Rachel Flanagan with
the Red Cross says donors like him are
rare about 60 to 70 percent of the
population can donate blood
approximately three percent do Edward
Bruce is another regular donor everybody
who uh good health and like that should
donate Flanagan says common reasons they
hear why people don't donate is because
it may hurt they don't have time or they
think they may get sick she says her
team's number one priority is the
donor's safety and health right now it's
about getting the blood supply up and
most of that donated blood stays right
here in Nevada we want to ensure that
our blood supply is very very strong
here so that way if our neighbors do
need it then we aren't putting any
strain on our system here recent changes
are allowing more people to donate with
the removal of the Mad Cow restriction
we are starting to see folks who
previously were just told they couldn't
donate who are actually at least going
through the process and seeing if they
can do it and next time you see a blood
drive make sure you do what it says give
blood reporting in Las Vegas Brian will
8 News Now